all right my talk on the table uh is our
next guest comedian Nate Barr gatesy
getsy I've been screwing it up for years
one of my favorite comedians Nate I will
never get it right I got it wrong on day
one and I can I can do two he's been
called the nicest man to stand up I
think might be actually I'm quoting
myself and he's known for jokes that are
relatable politics free and also clean
his new stand-up special on Prime video
is called hello world here's a clip
I miss being young your 20s are great
you're down for whatever
your friends call you they're like do
you want to go you're like I'll go you
don't even know where you're going
you're like I'll move dude I'll set my
apartment on fire what do you want to do
your 30s come and you're like where are
we going
how late are they open is it loud
I'm gonna drive separate
joins us now Nate welcome thank you you
know I I've been to the Blockbuster
you've been to Bend Oregon I've been to
that Blockbuster it's crazy like it's if
they have all they have brand new movies
brand new movies and you can go in there
and rent them and the one part about
this that was bad though if you didn't
return it I mean it would be like 30
grand
criminals
they go way up yeah yeah they're not
going to stop they're not and speaking
of not stopping this is a funny stand-up
special this is very good I love it it's
good on so many levels uh and one
difference and I've met your father I
went out to Nashville profiled you uh
you talk about your dad a lot in this
more so than in the other specials and
you kind of take them uh into a little
bit of criticism uh as changing in your
childhood going from the strictest
parents of all time to something a
little different how'd your dad feel
about that uh you know they get it they
laugh at it uh it's you know your
parents just changed like when you I was
the first I'm the oldest and uh so my
sister's 10 years younger of me so just
they were much more relaxed with her and
then as they've gotten my dad got a
tattoo uh I wasn't thrilled about that
because my sister got one and my dad got
one and my mom now found out she has one
and I was pretty upset about all of them
uh and so they just changed you know
your parents just get like yeah you were
saying that again with you but when it
came to your sister yeah I would get in
trouble for all the stuff they do now I
would be in big trouble you said you
think your sister was raised by her best
friends
because and also this is what I love
about your humor it's so relatable what
happens when you're over the age of 40
all the medical forms you have to fill
out and family family gatherings when
they say family history you go how many
diabetes do we have in the room how many
heart attacks somebody speak up
where does this come from for you Nate
that you've made the decision clearly
you're not raunchy you're relatable you
said you when you were little you
couldn't even say the word sucks you
don't even use that kind of language
yeah it was just very you know it was a
stricter back then I think and uh I just
started that way I never wanted to have
my parents be like embarrassed not that
you know I have like some Comics that
are can be dirty and I mean their
parents come to show I'm always I always
saying I'm a Comics parents comic so
like other Comics would be like well go
watch Nate like he's he's clean and he
can do it so it's just the way I started
and I lived in New York for like nine
years and uh so you just did you you
would kind of do your clean comedy and
then try to make it about it being clean
you're trying to Hope people don't
really notice but working for you you
keep that clean Persona throughout your
life I know on the podcast on Nate land
podcast you do but when you're sitting
at home watching the news with your
family yeah is it a little different no
no no it's uh yeah it stays clean it
just feels uh weird I mean you know it's
not I'm not perfect it's like you know
there could be a difference between
hanging out with comics and like when
I'm at home of course uh you know like
yeah but football like it's like the
locker room yeah where you have to like
go like oh you're with normal people now
yeah and you have to like so did you get
you had to go like I gotta calm it down
but it's yeah overall this is just yeah
it's just what I it's like it's personal
it's observational but I'm pretty sure
you observe things like Tony just
mentioned when you're watching the news
or some wild stuff happening in politics
you're like this would be hilarious on
stage but you decide not to go into
those things why you know a lot of uh a
lot of people do it they do it very well
and uh so it's like I just could feel
you sometimes can be tempted to think
you wanna you know you think I need to
say something about uh it's true but
then everybody's saying something
there's enough people saying some people
are smarter than me you don't need me I
just want to be uh a break well I said
were you a funny kid he goes well I
guess so and then showed me a picture of
him and his dad can we please go to the
picture of him and his dad a picture of
Nate and his dad when he was a little
boy do
your dad was is a magician now but he
was this is a clown there we go what was
your dad's clown name yo yo the clown
the clown so I'm thinking your humor has
to come from yo-yo it does come from
that we have it's great I don't know how
that picture we have there's pictures uh
of just be like they're trying to get
pictures of just me as a five-year-old
but then my dad's like makeup behind him
behind me because he was like about to
go to the show so yeah that was like
normal I'm at the Easter Bunny uh he
brought he brought he did a show at a
mall and the Easter Bunny needed a ride
home and he brought him over so you said
you named your special hello world after
something Tiger Woods said he when he
turned Pro he said hell I guess hello
world like when he turned when he was 18
turned Pro I wanted a nice greeting and
hello like I wanted something to be like
Pleasant and welcoming and then that's
also I'm a Giant Tiger fan so then hello
world was like his kind of thing so it
was kind of like a little bit of a
little knot congrats yeah special's
hilarious thank you so much good uh come
by again very soon I would love it hello
world now available on Prime video Nate
bargetzi